emmanuel l'europe bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors le premier
ministre jean castex va confirmer
c'était jeudi dernier la réouverture des
magasins non essentiels à la vie mais
très probablement sur une masse
territorialisées et vous refusez cette
idée de réouverture échelonné pourquoi
alors déjà je sais pas si on la refuse
vraiment en tout cas pour l'instant on
n'a pas discuté du coup du tout donc
c'est plutôt ça qui est surprenant mais
en fait sur le principe
notre inquiétude s'appuie sur le fait
qu'une grande partie de nos magasins est
fermé depuis le 1er février c'est
maintenant 3 mois c'est à dire déjà
davantage que ce qu'ils la fermeture
l'année dernière pour le premier
confirmant donc ça c'est ça une
inquiétude majeure puisque du coup les
réseaux les réseaux sont fragilisés
quand on parle de réseau de magasins
vous le savez ce sont des magasins qui
sont à la fois dans les centres
commerciaux et dans les centre-villes
également que ce qu'on veut éviter
surtout c'est la fragilisation de ces
réseaux donc si il y à des discussions à
avoir pour des raisons sanitaires
territoriales évidemment
de toute manière on est tout depuis le
début respectueux de ses problématiques
la preuve on est quasiment les seuls à
être fermées en tout cas dans dans
l'activité communiqué la parole à part
les restaurants et les salles de sport
et donc du coup notre notre cri d'alarmé
c'est éviter de déraper dans ces
problématiques de réouverture est en
tout cas notre souci c'est qu'on ne peut
pas en effet remet en faites pas pour
des raisons de transmission du virus à
l'intérieur des magasins mais pour des
raisons liées à la circulation des
français et la problématique de la
cohérence du raisonnement pour nous
c'est de savoir pourquoi on déciderait
de libérer la circulation des français
et de ne pas réouvrir les magasins c'est
plutôt une incompréhension ou en tout
cas un besoin de discussions urgentes
pour mettre en place des choses qui nous
permette de réouvrir très vite alors
vous demandé une réouverture le dit mais
pourquoi précisément cette date alors
sur la date
ce que je veux sur la date effectivement
là la problématique que nous défendons
c'est que il ya deux sujets un sujet
économique et sociale et un sujets
sanitaires le sujet économique et social
mais j'en ai parlé c'est retenu chaque
semaine de retard d'ouverture état et
mettent en danger des des réseaux est en
tout cas des magasins anti à l'intérieur
de ces réseaux pour des raisons à la
fois de coups de dead qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas ne sont pas là ils ne seront
pas là avant de nombreux mois pour des
raisons administratives et deuxième
sujet et sanitaires c'est que en fait on
a le souhait d'étaler les flux sur un
maximum de week-end notamment dans une
période comme elle ou qui est très
importante sur le plan du textile et qui
est très importante également en
préparation de la fête des mères sur 130
d'activités telles que la parfumerie ou
la bijouterie par exemple donc deux
sujets ne pas continuer de rester fermés
pour ne pas mettre en danger des
magasins et des emplois et ne pas avoir
des flux trop trop conséquents sur un
nombre restreint de week-end parce que
c'est vrai que sur la question des
protocoles sanitaires aujourd'hui les
commerces ni non essentiels ont des
solutions
en fait oui y'a même pas dessus il n'y a
même pas de discussions sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs
tout le monde le sait bien il ya eu en
fait nous sommes les seuls magasins
fermés il ya énormément de magasins
ouverts et notamment la grande
distribution mais d'autres et qui ne
pose aucun problème de nature sanitaire
donc ce n'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur des magasins on
avait renforcé le le moment le protocole
dès le mois de décembre et tout s'est
bien passé et heureusement il a été
encore renforcée par la suite la
question n'est même pas de discussions
en fait un gouvernement sur le sujet du
protocole dans le cadre des commerces
c'est bien la décision de se dire
arrêtons de entre guillemets de
sacrifier les commerces pour des raisons
de circulation des français à parce que
sinon on va prouver je vais s'en sortir
et vous avez une idée du nombre de
commerces qui pourrait mettre la clé
sous la porte si effectivement une
réouverture n'est n'est pas annoncée aux
alentours du 10 mai vous savez c'est
très compliqué parce qu'il ya un peu de
temps et il ya le court terme on sait
que le court terme et c'est vrai dans le
commerce comme dans d'autres activités
les défaillances sont reportés pour des
raisons des néo j'irai tant mieux à
court terme en fait ce qu'on m'avait
regardé nos sections n'ouvrait pas en
mai et que les aides n'arrivait pas à
temps en fait on avait 15 % des magasins
de des magasins et des des emplois qui
étaient directement en danger
mais ça c'est le court terme à plus long
terme pull et plus on est dans cette
situation la plus acteurs sont
fragilisés plus pour continuer de se
transformer ils manqueront de capacité
d'investissement et donc ils vont être
restructurés pour pouvoir investir donc
ça il y aura un deuxième effet
malheureusement dans l'est dans les
roues à dire 24 mois qui viennent qui
seront liées à la fragilisation très
forte d'un certain nombre d'activités
notamment celles qui ont été très
pénalisées déjà en 2020 et en début
d'année que sur le textile la parfumerie
la beauté santé ou la bijouterie alors d
inde depuis le début de
de la pandémie ont été annoncés
débloqués par le gouvernement
vous nous avez dit à deux reprises que
certains dans des commerces ne les ont
pas touché ces aides comment est ce que
vous vous l'expliquer en fait c'est lié
à un choix qui a été fait qui est
justifiée ni justifiable au départ qui
est le fait d avant tout les petits
commerçants dans le cas d'un fonds
solidarité qui existe depuis le début de
la crise et qui a très bien fonctionné
et tant mieux mais par contre la prise
en compte des réseaux c'est à dire des
entreprises un peu plus importante quand
je dis lui plus importante c'est pas
très importante c'est à partir de 15
magasins donc vous savez que dans les
réseaux en france il ya entre 300 et 700
magasins donc on est dans un schéma de
modalités d'être qui ne fonctionnait pas
pour des raisons de plafond premier type
dead a été mis en place s'appelle la
prise en charge des coûts fixes pour les
pour le début de l'année à partir du
début de l'année jusqu'à juin mais en
fait dans nos activités comme les
magasins ont fermé en février que ccn
fonctionne sur la base de deux mois en
fait les premières aides de cette nature
seront touchés en juin pour nos acteurs
il reste une seconde aide qui
malheureusement est en cours de
discussion encore avec la communauté
européenne et on espère que ça va
s'accélérer très rapidement qui est
requis et vise la prise en charge des
loyers et des charges locatives et celle
ci aussi compte tenu des problématiques
de temps de temps administratif et de
temps politique probablement qu'elle
sera pas touchée avant juin ou juillet
donc il ya un gros sujet de trésorerie
un gros sujet de décalage de perception
est pour l'instant effectivement il ya
l'aide évidemment du chômage partiel qui
est très importante mais c'est pas
suffisant du tout dans une période où
aujourd'hui le chiffre d'affaires et à
zéro
merci beaucoup emmanuel l'europe d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans la matinale
de rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
délégué général de promotion du commerce
spécialisé